all right grab your bone flute and
gather around the fire today on what if
we're taking you back to the time of
woolly mammoths and saber-toothed cats
yeah that's right you're living in the
stone age
if you were living day-to-day in this
primitive world what would you use as
tools
how would you communicate with anyone
and
would you have to eat your family
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you lived in the stone age
2.6 million years ago started a period
we call the stone age
and in this period that spanned almost
two and a half million years
our ancestors faced three ice ages
limited resources and
hungry predators
every day tested the limits of early
human endurance and challenged their
bodies and minds
the earth was plunged into ice ages for
hundreds of millions of years
the entire world was cold and dry
never warm enough to rain or snow
this was hell frozen over
but when temperatures rose
humans had to adapt
and fast
these early nomads wandered from one
area to the next never finding permanent
homes until much later in human history
so if you were in this group of
hunter-gatherers
what would you eat
you wake up in a dark cave next to a
dying fire
next to you your sleeping family is
huddled for warmth
put on your best fur it's time to
provide for this tribe
outside your cave you would find other
members of your group intense ready to
move at a moment's notice
you and your fellow hunter-gatherers
migrate like birds moving to wherever
the resources can feed you best
so now grab your spear made of bone and
wood
you learned how to craft it from
watching another tribe put one together
or maybe you were a genius ahead of your
time and created tools like this on your
own
scientists still aren't clear on how
much influence stone age humans had on
one another
why is this still shrouded in mystery
well that's because early humans weren't
communicating with each other on a high
level at this time
you would have to reverse engineer what
you've seen others use before
or wise up and learn to invent it
yourself
so what are you hunting with this weapon
you would be in search of woolly
mammoths
these massive beasts were the size of
african elephants and weighed around six
tons
you could follow their large footprints
to track them down
and you'd use fire to herd them to fall
off a cliffside
or you could spear one to death
yeah good luck with that
just one woolly mammoth could feed up to
30 people for two weeks
but
what if you weren't lucky enough to
catch this early mammal
well no worries you'll just gather nuts
and berries
or eggs from bird nests
there's even evidence to suggest early
humans used clay pots to cook their food
once they had everything they needed
lucky for you stone age humans were true
culinarians
tools found in the paleolithic age show
evidence that they may have created
flour from oats
how does some oat flatbread sound
a little bland
no problem just grab some garlic mustard
seeds turmeric or even some wild onions
you've cultivated
but if you're not careful
these spices could be used to season you
markings discovered on the bones of our
ancestors indicate that occasionally
we ate each other
yeah we even sucked out the marrow from
the bones
better sleep with that axe next to you
but these people didn't need food as an
excuse to kill each other
many skeletons from the late stone age
have
nasty head injuries
whether it was raids infighting or
all-out battles early humans led violent
lives that were often cut short by each
other
so when you're not out fighting for your
life or searching for food
what would you do for fun
well humans in this period were the
first to leave behind art
using a combination of minerals charcoal
and burnt bone meal
they created images of one another
animals and symbols
they even made flutes from bones
that's right you could have a jam
session around the fire
and you better make the most of every
day because the average lifetime in the
stone age maxes out at 40 years
just enough time to mate and have kids
but your dating pool would definitely be
limited
so
what if you married a family member
well don't have that awkward talk with
your cousin yet
just stay here because
that's a story
for another
what if
you